Immer wieder berichten wir hier bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction über die äußerst spannende
Suche nach außerirdischem Leben.
Und die Hinweise darauf werden immer erdrückender:
Eine neue Studie aus den USA zeigt jetzt,
dass der Exoplanet Kepler-186f wohl eine stabile
Rotationsachse und damit auch verlässliche
Jahreszeiten hat.
Und klar ist: Ein stabiles Klima begünstigt
die Entstehung von Leben natürlich enorm.
Handelt es sich bei Kepler-186f also noch
um viel mehr als nur einen erdähnlichen Exoplaneten
und wie wahrscheinlich ist dort außerirdisches
Leben wirklich?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Der Kanal mit der
täglichen Packung Internet.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
auch nichts.
herzlich willkommen
Vielen Dank für diesen spannenden Themenvorschlag,
den ihr mir über Whats App geschickt habt!
Zu meiner persönlichen Nummer für Themenvorschläge
und die tägliche Nachricht an auch persönlich
von mir mit dem Videolink vorab findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung!
Bei der Suche nach außerirdischem Leben konzentrieren
sich viele Forschungsteams auf die Entdeckung
sogenannter “erdähnlicher Exoplaneten”.
Meistens kreisen sie in der lebensfreundlichen,
also habitablen Zone ihres Muttergestirns,
und oft handelt es sich zudem um Felsplaneten.
Der größte Etappensieg der Astronomie wäre
sicherlich ein Planet, der genauso groß ist
wie die Erde und viel Wasser besitzt.
Zudem müsste er nicht zu weit und nicht zu
nah seinen Heimatstern umkreisen und so Leben
ermöglichen!
Mehr als 100 Exoplaneten wurden bereits entdeckt,
die ähnlich klein wie die Erde sind, doch
die meisten von ihnen haben eben nicht diesen
lebensfreundlichen Abstand zu ihrem Heimatstern.
Doch der Exoplanet Kepler-186f passt exakt
in die gewünschte Kategorie: Er ist 500 Lichtjahre
von uns entfernt und gehört zu einem anderen
Planetensystem.
Kepler-186f befindet sich in der bewohnbaren
Zone seines Sterns, dem Roten Zwerg, und umkreist
ihn einmal in 130 Tagen.
Der Exoplanet ist etwa zehn Prozent kleiner
als unser Heimatplanet - hat also eine erdähnliche
Größe.
Das Kepler-Weltraumteleskop hatte ihn 2014
erspäht, als er vor seinem Heimatstern vorbeigezogen
war.
Er gehört er zu den rund 20 Exoplaneten,
die wir kennen und die sich in bewohnbaren
Zonen befinden.
Doch die anderen in dieser Kategorie sind
deutlich größer als die Erde und Forschungsteams
können sich nicht sicher sein, ob sie aus
Fels- oder Gas bestehen.
Und als würde Kepler-186f nicht schon genug
den Wunschträumen der Astronomen-Teams entsprechen,
verdichten sich die Hinweise, dass er sogar
noch erdähnlicher ist als bisher angenommen.
Denn ein Forschungsteam aus Atlanta hat jetzt
herausgefunden, dass die Neigung seiner Rotationsachse
sehr stabil ist - vergleichbar also mit der
Erdachse.
Dazu schreibt das Forschungsteam: "Die Achsenneigung
eines Planeten bestimmt die dort herrschenden
Jahreszeiten und das Klima, da von ihr abhängt,
wie viel Licht auf die Planetenoberfläche
wo und wann auftrifft".
Auf dieser Grundlage können wir also davon
ausgehen, dass die Jahreszeiten auf Kepler-186f
gleichmäßig hintereinander abfolgen und
so insgesamt für ein stabiles Klima auf dem
Exoplaneten sorgen.
Eine solche stabile Neigung der Rotationsachse
sei übrigens auch bei der Super-Erde Kepler-62f
zu beobachten, die 1200 Lichtjahre von unserer
Erde entfernt ist.
Wie bestimmend die Stabilität der Achse ist,
zeigt die Geschichte des Mars.
Seine Achse schwankte wohl im Laufe der Zeit
zwischen 0 und 60 Grad - und so verlor der
einst feuchte Mars seine Atmosphäre und wurde
zur Wüstenwelt.
Ob Kepler-186f tatsächlich also außerirdischem
Leben ein Zuhause bietet, steht noch nicht
wirklich fest, denn mit den heutigen Teleskopen
können wir die Atmosphäre von Planeten nicht
direkt beobachten.
Doch es gibt Hoffnung und die nächste Generation
der Instrumente, könnte dazu tatsächlich
in der Lage sein.
Wir bleiben da natürlich dran.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert am besten auch den englischen
Kanal (hier einfach draufklicken) von Clixoom.
Da gibt es auch die ein oder andere Videopremiere.
Glocke nicht vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit: The First picture of Earth and moon!
Stay tuned, see you soon!